ich kann natürlich nicht sagen ob ich
noch mal antreten werde weil ich kann
nicht in die zukunft gucken aber im
moment ist es nicht geplant und ich
glaube es ist es ist für mich war es von
anfang an so eine sache dass ich gesagt
habe okay das ist das macht man einmal
und dann nicht mehr das letzte mal dass
ein interpret aus deutschland glaube ich
zwei mal oder mehrere male hin geschickt
wurde das ist schon über 30 jahre her
deswegen das ist absolut unüblich darum
habe ich mir über diese frage noch nie
wirklich ernsthafte gedanken gemacht
wenn es so sein würde dass man mich
anspricht und fragen würdest du nicht
noch mal gerne wollen oder oder das an
mich ran tragen würde dann würde ich das
auf jeden fall überlegen und abwägen und
jetzt nicht sofort nein rufen oder so
sondern aber aber selber würde ich mich
glaube ich nicht dafür
anmelden oder zur verfügung stellen